e muitas vezes eu me pergunto o que leva
alguém cometer uma Sacre sobre outro
alguém o que que leva o grupo de pessoas
um grupo de pensamento achar que é justo
que é legítima uma sacar outras pessoas
quando eu me conecto o massacre de sabra
e chatila qual eu aqui que eu falo sou
sobrevivente fico me perguntando como é
que as pessoas podem cometer tamanha
violência uns com os outros isso me faz
refletir de uma importante para aqui
nesse Ted a gente pensa a gente Pense
como é que a gente pode ser tão violento
na nossa
a potência de expoente tanta violência o
massacre de sabra e chatila acontece no
momento em que hoje não estava acometido
por uma guerra civil e provavelmente uma
guerra que coloca pessoas vizinhos
irmãos uns contra os outros e avião
campos de concentração de palestinos na
tanto de Santo Sábado fomos tranquila E
esses tempos refugiados eles eram
oriundos de 1948 quando de criação do
Estado de Israel não se fez a coisa
correta de uma forma amor e essas
pessoas de 48 um deles anamã pai ou se
você Êxodo se mudar para outros países
então vejam vocês o outro país recebe de
repente pessoas e Sofia um problema
muito rápido o que tá faltando isso por
você importante entender
os israelenses e palestinos Árabes e
judeus são primos de primeiro grau e tem
história sabe de que o massacre dos
judeus Torres em sido uma das coisas
mais nas pastas mais terríveis da
história da humanidade uma das tragédias
que jamais a gente deve se esquecer No
entanto quando a gente não cuida da
violência quando a gente não trata da
violência por devida atenção acaba
gerando o que aconteceu e o que é que
aconteceu esses primos de primeiro grau
passaram a guerrear dessa guerra duas
podem ter oito e por quê porque é
impossível a gente conviver
tranquilamente quando você não tem o
diálogo a comunicação a parte um
instrumento Fundamental e único pra
existência da humanidade com
tranquilidade então vejam vocês
é justo judeus que sofreram os fazer uma
calça jeans reproduzem através de Gaza
mantendo o povo de Gaza Praticamente em
condicionamento eles tiram todos os
direitos dos palestinos constroem um
muro isola eles Evidente como disposto
de proteçao Mas o que está por detrás
disso é uma loucura maior é a falta de
diálogo a falta de possibilidade de
Fugas tá então a partir disso eu tomei
uma decisão na vida e eu iria enfrentar
um todas as forças a violência por faz
como é que a gente pode fazer isso vamos
entrar em contato com grande comecei ver
como é que grandes os seus como é que
Mandela fez comecei a perceber como é
que marca Luther King dia eu percebi que
havia uma possibilidade de enfrentar a
violência não violência cultura de paz
eles nosso trabalho dando cursos
e por isso alguém me apresenta produtos
e já leu o livro comunicação
não-violenta de Marshall missionários
não não havia lido E aí quando eu vi o
mesmo sem muito engraçado você tirou ela
um jeito da gente cuidado violência
assim trabalhando fui percebendo onde
que tem alguns pontos cuidado precisa
ser expulsos aparecia outras questões e
fui percebendo que havia chegado a hora
de um começar não mais falar de
comunicação não violenta mas quem sabe
falando de uma publicação pacífica E aí
é o nesse processo Porque o macho fala
que a primeira coisa a gente identificar
necessidade eu faço uma mudança dizendo
que a primeira coisa a gente a
identificar sentimento e sucesso como
que a gente pudesse abrir o leque muito
diferente pelo olhar muito diferente
sobre a questão por quê Porque eu
descobri essencialmente nós somos
analfabeto
a notícia não sabe sentir aquele que não
Alfabetizado porque na nossa educação a
gente foi educado e criado por quê para
pensar penso logo existo agora e aí a
gente faz se desconectando o sentimento
então por exemplo se eu tô diante de uma
dificuldade eu sinto medo socialmente eu
não posso dizer isso então eu recuei não
sabe o número do que tem eu tô por
exemplo inseguro eu não posso demonstrar
insegurança então nos treinamentos para
trabalhar na empresa você preparado
somente para pensar nessa você não é
preparado Por que humanamente Para você
reconhecer o medo que você tem não há
espaço para isso então eu comecei a
trabalhar o alfabeto do sentiu sinto
medo sinto raiva Sinto dor sinto nojo
sinto angústia EA partir disso criar uma
possibilidade da pessoa poder fluir em
cima
a nomear seu sentimento e aí quando vem
uma história mais violenta você tem a
possibilidade de dizer essa pessoa
calmamente quando você fala comigo neste
tons quando você fala comigo desse jeito
eu me sinto humilhado eu me sinto
desrespeitado quando você fala nesse tom
para mim se tornar muito você poderia
falar muito mais baixo comunicação
pacífica né eu tenho na sociedade de ser
o time errado eu tenho necessidade de
ser amado eu tenho necessidade de
serviço de ser olhado e a partir disso
as pessoas começaram a perceber que
quando alguém vem pro à tarde e você
responde por paz uma técnica chamada
comunicação pacífica e não é samba
técnica no sentido de técnico da palavra
necessitam pelo uso da comunicação para
trazer Liberdade
a seleção para as pessoas estão em um
exemplo muito interessante disso eu
morava em São Paulo na Vila Mariana e
ele estava vindo pela Avenida Ibirapuera
e ali no final da Avenida Dona Clara em
um complexo de água conhecido pelos
paulistanos do Cebolinha ele tem três
Palitos lá as três saídas mensagem as
três então provavelmente o que aconteceu
nesse Episódio traído porque o
Oi Que hora que você não me assusto na
ele fala assim errado está distraído tá
cego o seu tá sendo feliz não não
tô cego distraído Ou seja eu falei para
ele tá coçando quando parou lá na frente
que São Paulo isso a gente discute por
cinco metros que ali na curva eu já
falamos nós dois ele tava drogado que eu
também porque assim olha você me
desculpa realmente muito estranho
provavelmente deve ser fechado e não
poder fazer o segundo problema seria uma
honra seja Dizer para vocês que não é
uma coisa
e francamente impossível agora o que é
importante a gente entender que juntos
Detergente tem que praticar algumas
coisas que são essenciais na vida a
gente tem uma maneira de divulgar o
tempo inteiro a gente tem mania de
avaliar o tempo inteiro gente tem mania
de interpretar o tempo inteiro então a
base da comunicação pacífica não jogou
ela não avaliar e não é essa é a base
fator importante e quando a gente tem
uma notícia imediatamente a gente não
chata fonte da Notícia a gente sai em
disparada fazendo julgamento rapidamente
a gente faz decisão de amor nossa mas
que absurdo na coco pode tão pessoa
fazer isso eu respondo muito tratante de
panela
é o que eu tô percebendo Então faz isso
agora eu posso fazer uma pergunta por
que a maior contribuição a gente pode
ter falado o que é que te leva a fazer
dessa forma porque você faz desse jeito
que você tem a possibilidade de explicar
e talvez você se Surpreenda explicação
deles só não tinha pensado por esse
Prisma eu nunca vi isso a situação por
esse Então a partir do momento que você
aprender com certeza incrível infantário
o que eu quero dizer para você que eu
mais sofri muito tempo de violência Por
que só o fato do meu nome é a gente quer
dizer o meu pai faleceu e
em vendas a origem e principalmente
quando recentes camas primeira pergunta
pessoas falar mas no céu muçulmanos nos
estados e você percebe que as perguntas
são para formar um conjunto de obra para
entender se você ao terrorista se você é
violento e Engraçado que as pessoas não
conseguem perceber e por de trás da
violência tem algo para dizer não mas a
gente precisa fazer aquilo que a gente
vem fazendo na contra Mao a gente tem
falado muito esforço bandido bom é
bandido bom é bandido morto não é um
o bandido bom é bandido tratado curado
compreendido acolhido G inserido na
sociedade Este é o único caminho tem
gente que diz ah mas isso é o tópico
isso é muito lindo essa pessoa só fica
bonito para você falado numa palestra do
império mas na prática isso não se
aplica se aplica assim se aplica porque
quando você entende o que que leva o
outro a cometer a violência quando você
entende de que lugar ele na raça
violência através da sua atitude você
começa a procurar uma coisa que muitos
acham que só tá no campo do religioso e
a questão do perdão porque perdão parece
que do jeito que não foi narrado pelas
religiões é algo que você tem que
simplesmente aceitar a violência eu
quero que vocês saibam que perdão e nada
tem a ver
E como esquecer perdoar Definitivamente
não esquecer perdoar compreender quando
a gente outra and nem sentença o que
levou aquela pessoa cometerá querida
dito isso vamos dar uma possibilidade de
perdoar e ajudar essa pessoa a sair
deste lugar antes anos atrás quando eu
resolvi trabalhar com questões complexas
como utilizadores sexuais e também sobre
algo de violência entre profissionais da
Psicologia dizendo que era um absurdo eu
fizesse furar de utilizadores sessões na
inclusive são mais conhecidos como
abusadores operadores é intercedendo
essas pessoas estão nas famílias era pai
era mãe para tia para irmão é um vizinho
antimetil de modelo essas pessoas estão
nosso meio a
a parte da nossa vida é Preciso olhar
para isso tem que ser a gente vai
continuar estudando gelo cuidando de
fogo só não te dar 20 safado juntos anos
o muita gente aderiu à isso hoje a gente
ter resultados incríveis de gente
percebeu que 94,7 por cento estudados de
2018 altcow utilizadores que esses que
nós atendemos desta população foram
vítimas de violência na infância ou seja
esses tratados a gente tem zero por
cento de residência o que isso significa
significa que ser gente não enfrentar a
cultura de violência a gente não sinal
que está no campo da inadequação se a
gente não ensinar esses homens de que
este uso da sexualidade está no campo
inadequados
a mente fazer uma nova educação da
sexualidade ensinando a gente forma
ouvir entendem sentimento deles e por
isso é importante serão alfabetizados no
sentir aí a gente vai com certeza
evoluir cada vez mais e cada vez mais a
gente deve ser próximo a comunicação
pacífica ela tem esses Passos
fundamental identificar rapidamente o
que é que eu sou identificar rapidamente
o que é necessário conforme a
necessidade que não passando atendida
para não ser violento e depois eu posso
ter um tempo para fazer uma observação
sem avaliação os espaços eu posso ser
mais assertivo de isso sabe Para que
serve só para a gente ter discussões
filosóficas
e também sabe mas sabe-se também que o
meu dia a dia para você cuidar 12 volts
eu prestar atenção como o outro se sente
quando eu falo daquela forma porque eu
uso acesso pensam esse tom de voz o
tamanha potência porque não cabe nos
essa voz é alta ou baixa mas eu posso
dizer essa potência é exageradamente do
aparelho então o convite meu filho que a
gente possa fazer isso de uma forma de
tranquilo ganhar o único eu marco a
famosa não só marca Meu gatinho mas eu
faço eu quero reproduzir a fala dele a
água do rio
me mata de raiva Dream na sucesso em
tudo avatares eu tenho sono se você tem
um sonho é preciso que você vá para a
sala espero que se pede pro só trazer a
vocês o desejo de compartilhar esse
sonho o sonho de uma cultura de paz o
sonho de uma cultura de amor o sonho de
daquilo que o Rappa nos convida dizendo
a minha alma está armada e apontada para
cara de ser essa área da prevenção usa
mais fácil sem voz não é paz amigo a
gente não confirmou a gente olhar para o
mundo escolher ele e suportá-lo para que
ele possa também nos ajudar na arte de
viver em paz pela descida vocês por esse
encontro espero que vocês possam através
dessas palavras desse tipo muita
Velocidade sem reger uma forma perfeita
de sermos um
e o tempo inteiro de buscar
incessantemente conviver e melhora
gratidão a todos vocês um excelente
momento de vida que a gente possa logo
logo Samsung juntos Unidos na cultura de
paz quanto teremos um